it's a moment where we see maharani in
her element
she has power she has a career she has
success she has a showbiz
empire if you will and and it's a chance
for us to see how slavishly devoted her
fans out to her how she
is she is their voice and and and gives
uh
a meaning to their lives through the
song that she sings
in the 10th show ma's community to me
it's church
it's a it's a preacher and their
congregation
in in chicago it's show biz
that friday night i saw viola's bahraini
in complete command of her
[Music]
way audience go and they are
single-handedly the best group of extras
i have
ever seen in my entire
life and i know the fact that ann roth
explained to each and every one of them
sort of the origins of
all of their costumes everything that
they had on them went down the road
down the road yep yep when i pulled up
there was ann explaining
what this is your first introduction to
maharani
in her element i was surprised
at how it made me
tap into the part of myself that i
usually hide from
you know i'm i'm not a flashy girl at
all
for some reason it just catapulted me
out of that
everything that i had everything that i
had in me my sexuality
my confidence everything was in
vast display and had to be it was a
liberating scene
it's one of the reasons why you know i
went into acting too
is to be catapulted back in time and not
to just
bustles and corsets but back in time
where it was culturally specific
back in time where i saw a place for
[Applause]
myself
and george wasn't there like this one
woman that was really really old and you
actually
just got the close-up of her she's 90
she was
97 and i said one of the second ads over
to say
i got a close-up of you you can go home
and she says no i'm not leaving
this is what it felt like when i was
young
[Applause]
the movie really um
came alive that night i remember it
vividly when viola
as ma rainey came on to this set
you could feel this
palpable energy that i have never felt
before
on any movie i've ever worked on and and
we had them
and viola kept them all night long
and being in this big tent and having
all this the smell of the straw the hay
bales
it just it was transporting
and viola just held them in her hand
she held the audience in her hand the
whole night
viola could you feel the audience during
that whole thing
yes i could feel the audience because i
had to look at them
i had to i had to flirt with all the
dudes
in in the audience you know as a part of
you know
my act
[Music]
there was this moment where viola esma
and the extras as
people in barnesville georgia met
and the energy exchange was
so pure
[Music]
going from the tent to the stage by the
time she gets to the blue dress
she is trying to appeal to the masses
i wanted to challenge the notion of
something
being a little imperfect i wanted
authenticity with the makeup and you
know she was described as being someone
when she performed that under the lights
makeup looked like it was melting like
grease paint
so i wanted to challenge a woman getting
up there who looked like
whatever happened to baby jane because i
think
that people have an idea of what a star
looks like
and it's not specific you know the
universal is in the specificity
and so what would the specific look like
during the chitlin circuit shows when
you don't have a sergio lopez
as your makeup artist when you have heat
and no air conditioning
when you've probably been under those
lights for lord knows how long
when you don't have any sense of really
how to put on makeup and it's melting
and all of that
that's what i wanted people to see
that's the intro that i wanted
i didn't want to assimilate for a while
audience
in order for you to be able to digest
my rainy if i'm there i want you to be
there
yeah hence the makeup hence the gold
teeth
because she had a mouthful of gold teeth
she did you could see it in the pictures
um and her wig was made of horse hair
that's just the truth
she's putting on a show at the grand
theater and so that's
happening and so the dancers are there
and the band is playing but that's not
the story that we're watching
the spectacle is there so that therefore
on a certain look when
when mothers are then we cut to the
dances going
as a percussive visual element to accent
the moment so the audience is clear oh
that matters
so i'm using the rhythms to enhance
the the personality dynamics that we're
just starting to learn
i wanted to by the end of this whole
sequence for the audience to
understand the story dynamics that were
at play
before one line of dialogue is heard
that's what i was gonna say